vassilakou netz bekommen bei einem neuen
video hier am wunderschönen sonntag in
den ferien und jahr für heute habe ich
mir mal was ganz kreatives einfallen
lassen
und zwar geht es heute um fünf arten von
verschiedenen telefonpartner hat sie
irgendwie ein bisschen pervers und auf
jeden fall ist mir da kein anderer name
eingefallen also habe ich mir gedacht
nennt es einfach fünf arten von
telefonpartner so und dann will ich auch
gar nicht lange lagern ich würde sagen
gefangen direkt mal an und zwar mit typ
1 und typ 1 ist der lügner ich werde
hier können sie alle
sie sind am telefon und ihr wisst alle
ganz genau dass sie lügen aber irgendwie
keine ahnung was auf kollege wie sieht
es jetzt aus hier mit dem geld weil du
weißt du schuld es nur noch 100 euro
ich habe mich nicht von je 100 euro
geliehen
sorry aber ich bin jetzt war doch mitten
in der stadt ja bald überhaupt keine
zeit vielleicht hast du auch die autos
im hintergrund auf jeden fall ich bin es
in zwei wochen oder so wieder zu hause
kann es ja dann nur bei mir melden wer
tut mir tut mir leid
der empfang ist auch nicht so gut merke
ich gerade also versucht einmal später
noch mal und ich habe eigentlich auch
keine ahnung von doris also hat auch ein
schock und dann kommen wir jetzt schon
zu typen immer zwei und zwar ist dass
sie der typ ja ist ja klar beim
telefonieren kann man den
gesprächspartner nicht sehen aber er ist
vom telefon und gestikuliert einfach in
ein natur obwohl das ja eigentlich gar
keinen sinn ergibt ja also pass auf ich
kann das geld auf jeden fall geben nur
das verzögert sich halt um so ein ganz
kleines bisschen weil ich musste da also
was erzähle ich war unterwegs und dann
bin ich so gegangen und hat das geld
dabei und dann ist das aus meiner tasche
rausgefallen und ja dann habe ich halt
verloren und ich habe es auch irgendwie
überhaupt nicht wiedergefunden
deswegen muss ich erst ein bisschen
jetzt arbeiten bis ich halt wieder hat
und tut mir leid also gebt mir einen
monat ein monat nur oder zwei vielleicht
und den typ 3 könnt ihr sicherlich auch
alle das ist genau dieser typ der
einfach nicht auf den punkt kommt der
sitzung
aber er kommt einfach nicht auf den
punkt ja du passt auf ich musste da so
was erzählen
ja du kriegst das auf jeden fall nur da
ist halt so was vorgefallen
und ja also ich hatte das geld schon so
ziemlich zusammen bzw fasst zusammen
also fast ganz zumindest und dann kann
man also einen vorfall aber ich das
jetzt bitte nicht weil das passiert ja
also das war also das geld hatte ich
schon fast alles komplett schon gesagt
hab ich ja immer gesagt und ja aber
bitte versprechen auch dass du nicht sag
ich muss das jetzt eigentlich sagen
traue ich mich gar nicht etwas zu sagen
und dann sind wir jetzt auch schon bei
tipp nummer 4 und 2 ist dass dieser typ
der ein ganz kleines bisschen übertreibt
ganz klein bisschen aber nur wer also
etwas auf es kam also zu kleinen
komplikationen sag ich mal und ich
erzählt das jetzt mal aber du musst mir
das auf jeden fall glauben auch wenn es
jetzt sich ein bisschen unrealistisch
anwalt aber ich schwöre es war wirklich
so cook ich war auf der autobahn glaube
ich was die lange es war die autobahn
wie bei alarm für cobra 11 ich war auf
der autobahn unterwegs dann bin ich da
so gefahren und wird sie kommt von
hinten so ein hubschrauber polizeiauto
ist dann halt fliegt der hubschrauber so
über mich drüber und hält dann vor mir
ne und dann kommen die da so raus mit
waffen und da musste ich aussteigen dann
haben sie mir das geld abgezogen und
dann sind die einfach weggefahren und
jetzt ist das geld natürlich weg und ich
weiß jetzt einfach nicht was ich machen
soll
ja das ist jetzt auch ehrlich kein
scheiß ich weiß auch gar nicht warum
jetzt ausgerechnet ich und nicht
irgendwie irgendjemand anderes und dann
haben wir zum schluss natürlich noch den
fünften typen und zwar ist das genau
dieser typ der am telefon mit und euch
einfach voll aber er hat gar nicht schon
irgendwas zum thema beizutragen über das
ihr euch gerade unterhalten weil er
einfach in ein naturbad ja also bei mir
ist auch alles super in
in butter oder wie es auch immer nennt
soll auf jeden fall bei mir läuft
zurzeit so gut ja und auch nochmal auf
den auftritt der nächste woche bezogen
hier wir haben doch hier so ein auftritt
oder beziehungsweise wir müssen ins
auftritt doch managen und ich habe mir
schon genauen plan überlegt und zwar
machen wir so einfach so wir gehen dahin
und dann müssen wir natürlich erst mal
mit dem ganzen team die bühne aufbauen
dann brauchen wir die ganzen
lichteffekte müssen wir da hin bauen und
hab ich gern noch fast subakute gute
gutes mutes meinte ich hab mich grad
versprochen tut mir leid was super gut
ist für uns beide überlegt und zwar
gehen wir einfach in manchen deinen
beziehen uns schon seriös an
damit sie alle denken ja die haben geld
die die haben kontakte und ja so gehen
wir da einfach hin und ich denke du bist
damit einfach startete schnauze oder
nicht wir reden so läuft jetzt sind wir
hier auch leider schon wieder am ende
des videos und ich hoffe natürlich es
hat euch sowie mal gefallen und auch
falls das der fall ist dann wird es mich
echt freuen wenn ihr diesem video einen
daumen nach oben gibt wenn nicht dann
gibt natürlich auch einfach den daumen
nach oben wie immer und mich willst
natürlich noch interessieren auf welchen
typen ihr jetzt andauern trefft ist es
der lügner der übertreiber der der
news.com oder blah blah blah keine haare
also schreibt es der firma bitte und in
die kommentare
so leute und hier unten rechts und links
geht's jetzt zu meinen letzten beiden
videos check ist auf jeden fall weiß
abbitte und ja wenn ich nichts mehr
verpassen wollt dann abonniert doch
einfach meinen kanal checkt auf jeden
fall die anderen videos auch alle wenn
ihr rock pop und die noch nicht kennt
und ja und in der video beschreibung
findet ihr dann noch links zu ast fm zu
instagram zum facebook und so weiter
können die auch im abdecken bei bedarf
auf jeden fall sein sonst
bis zum nächsten treffen